today I made a watermelon steak which is  honestly a vegan alternative to a steak  but it's also a little bit better than a  steak so uh what I did was I started by  patting dry a steak throwing a bunch of  salt on it getting a little oil in the  pan getting that pan nice and hot  heating up this watermelon so that it's  gonna be the best steak you've ever  heard a little time in the pan for some  flavor but watermelon has its own flavor  so you don't really need as much as you  would with the regular steak which  doesn't have as much flavor put it on a  plate with some perfectly cooked carrots  and some asparagus after I was done  searing it and cut it open and look at  that it's a perfect medium rare